Russia says Ukrainian drones have
attacked the Moscow area for a fifth
consecutive night in krasnagos just
outside Moscow a drone was shot down
crashing into a high-rise apartment
block it caused minor damage with no
casualties reported Moscow airports
halted flights for several hours Marsha
said it jammed another two drones near
bransk in the south west let's speak to
journalist Julia Chapel of Oliver she
joins us now for more on this from
Moscow Julia give us more details on
this attack and how people are reacting
now to these multiple drone strikes
yeah that's right according to reports
we're getting the Russian Ministry of
Defense actually repelled an attack of
drones and altogether six drones uh were
repelled uh two were shot down in the
Moscow region to in the Border region of
briansk as you say and two more in the
northwest of Crimea all of them were
destroyed uh either by air defense
systems or jammed by electronic warfare
equipment by the way according to the
Moscow mayor when he was speaking about
the latest attack that took place
overnight in the Northwestern suburb of
Moscow some strike drones not
reconnaissance drones were used he
didn't specify the whether they were
carrying an explosives or not
potentially they could they could while
a Russian Ministry of Defense blamed the
Ukrainian side of course for their
attacks that they normally do sadly it's
becoming the new normal to speak almost
daily about Duran tax on the Russian
territory as for people they're
contemplating what is going on remaining
mostly silent so far apparently their
silence will last until the first
casualties caused by the strikes will
take place however today we saw some
footage on the internet of people
expressing their discontent and
grumbling while on the plane of course
people are unhappy with the closure of
the airports and Moscow and fly delays
but apparently they refused to realize
that they are also participants in this
conflict whether they like it or not and
the closure of airports is a necessary
measure to prevent the worst case
scenario as drones of course pose a
great danger to planes and civilians
indeed Yulia Chapel brings the latest
there from Moscow thanks very much